good evening from London welcome to
peers Morgan uncensored it's almost four
years now since Harry and Megan made the
groundbreaking announcement they were
quitting the royal family stepping down
as senior roles moving to the United
States and finding Freedom well since
that moment they've systematically and
relentlessly exploited their existing
Royal status to make as much money as
possible while simultaneously trashing
the Royals and the monarchy to preserve
their exposure and relevance I think
it's time we brought the susic circus to
a formal end conservative MP Bob cely is
now introducing a bill in Parliament to
strip them formly of their titles the
Duke and Duchess can be Mr and misses
like the rest of us he said someone
doesn't want to be a royal that's a
decision we respect they shouldn't keep
the titles and privileges if they trash
an institution that plays an important
part in our nation's life I think he's
right and as he also says the baseless
racism claims that are now embroil the
king and Princess of Wales will they
should be the final straw shouldn't they
the author behind those damning claims
who claims he wasn't the author behind
those daming claims but who else could
he have been the author of those damning
claims given it was in a manuscript of
his own book in which these damning
claims were made sassic lab dog Omid
scobby is still tying himself in the web
of his own lies yeah what a what a
series of events right um and what a
frustrating experience for me for a book
that was so heavily vetted legal eyes
dotted te's crossed and a book that I
was extremely proud of now completely
overshadowed by an event that has caused
me a lot of frustration as well we've
have a full investigation going on into
the series events that
happened yeah I know you're frustrated
buddy but um imagine how frustrated King
Charles is or the Princess of Wales that
somehow they got called racists in a
manuscript you claim you didn't actually
draft that way that's frustrating isn't
it when the entire world is encouraged
to think that you were named as racist
little bit more frustrating than you not
being able to work out why a draft of
your own book appeared in the
Netherlands and was translated from a
copy that had the names on it that was
sent to them apparently by your agent
how did your agent get that if you
didn't write it does your agent write
your book
soid well the times has reported like I
said the earlier version of the book did
contain the names and it was sent to the
Dutch publisher Harry and Megan stood by
and stunning silence so un likee them
isn't it when private conversations of
the kind that Megan had with Charles in
private letters began to circulate in
this book as well containing the names
of the two people that she and Harry
claim were racially insensitive about
the potential skin color of their baby
now these two can't normally wait to set
the record straight to sue to go to
court to hold people to proper account
for invasion of private corresp
respondence or
conversations why aren't they doing it
now they claim that they had nothing to
do with osc's new book but you might
remember Megan claiming that about his
last book and then a strange thing
happened she was suing a newspaper
ironically for invading her privacy over
private correspondents rather similar to
the situation we find ourselves in here
and when it came to the court case after
the book had been published that she had
nothing to do with she was forced to
apologize because it turned out that not
only had she had something to do with it
she'd given briefing notes to her Aid to
go to a meeting with osobi and brief him
for the book so she was a primary source
for that book so I don't know what you
make of the Silence from the sussexes
we're into nearly week two now of a
deafening damning
silence weird right well the question of
whether they should keep their titles in
my view comes down to this and it's that
if you're going to spark a race route if
you're going to accuse two senior
members of our royal family of being
racists and if you're going to then
deliberately not say the names for two
years so the whole world speculates over
which member of this white supremacist
family was racist tiring them all with
the brush if you're going to do that and
then calmly as Harry did it started this
year suddenly go oh we didn't mean to
say they were racists no no no no this
was unconscious bias that thing when
someone isn't racist but someone says
they were thinking it it was that but we
all know what we heard on
Oprah and in my view they made their
racial charge bed and they now should
lie in it and you can't accuse the king
of this country or the wife of our
future king of this country of being
racist and in my opinion keep the Royal
titles that you've been so cynically
fleecing for the last four years or
maybe you can let's have a debate about
this journalist Rachel Johnson talk to V
contributor Paula Ron Adrian associate
editor of the mirror Kevin Maguire and
the author and historian Sir Anthony
Seldon so a fantastically high-powered
panel tonight Sir Anthony let me start
with you purely kind of constitutionally
historically is it even possible to
wrestle the titles away from them
well I I'm sure it is Piers the question
is is it all worth it and is it going to
be what they want because it just makes
them more out to be victims of these uh
hateful exploitative people in
Buckingham Palace wouldn't it just be
better uh just to to to let them uh be
forgotten and not to react because by
reacting by doing this the Bob sely idea
uh I think it just makes them into
victims gives them even more publicity
there they are over uh all the world's
headlines again as people there must be
some truth surely in what they're uh
both saying and I I think that that is
not the right way to handle it they're
both clearly two very very damaged
people uh they need help I don't think
they need stripping their role titles
see I would question that I would say
they're very damaging people uh I'm not
saying they haven't been through D two
but I think they're very I think they've
set out to be deliberately damaging to
the royal family and the monarchy
they've taken hundreds of millions of
dollars to do it it's it is
unprecedented in history for two
Renegade Royals to go off and enrich
themselves making money out of targeting
the royal family isn't it we've never
seen this
before it's not almost unprecedented
Pier it is unprecedented for two members
of the the royal family deliberately to
set out hurt harm belittle besch the the
the Monarch and the wife of the heir to
the throne that's
unprecedented uh of course it's damaging
but of course the damaging action comes
out of damaged people the question is I
think just what's the best way to do it
and I think uh myself to best way to
deal with it is not to give them the
oxygen of even more entitlement to the
claim of being victims okay Rachel
Johnson your view well Sir Sir Anthony
as ever as an eminent historian has uh
put the argument for killing with
kindness and don't don't give the
grifters any more GFF to the the
grifters make most of their money
because of course they have Royal titles
the American business model collapses if
they're just playing Harry and Megan not
immediately but it would over time if
they can't slap all over all their
correspondents that they're the jke and
Duchess it disappears
possibly that remains to be seen we do
not know that it could definitely give
them another leg on their you know
grievance tour um I want to know I mean
Bob cely who is the Le man of life and
limb who's you know withdrawn the
Flaming Scabbard to defend the monarchy
and he's he's inserted this bill this
private members bill which is course
something like the disinheritance of
titles Bill 1917 it must be your notes
yeah so my question is it's been just to
be clear it's been used before to remove
the titles of his Ro highness Charles
Edward Duke of Albany Earl of Clarence
Baron Arlo his Royal Highness Ernest
Augustus the Duke of Cumberland and
tevia Dale and ear of armar and so on
this has been used a lot but wasn't it
mainly used to strip Germans of their
titles in 1917 but the Curious irony is
if you took the title Duke of Sussex
away from Prince Harry he'd be Harry
Mount baton which is a German surname
anyway so I'm sure he wouldn't like it I
think okay so the question is who has
the right to strip these Royals of their
titles is it the House of Commons or is
it the queen and she took away Princess
Di's HR which caused Princess Di which I
campaigned for her not to do by the way
huge upset and hurt that was a a
terrible wound yeah for Princess Diana
this this would no doubt be a terrible
wound for Harry and Megan because the
Royals their titles is who they are you
know my the difference about di was she
never attacked the monarchy she had her
issue with her ex-husband but I I
campaigned at the mirror to stop her HR
being taken away CU I knew how much it
hurt because she told me and because it
was only taken away because she was
deemed to no longer be married to
Charles right but she didn't attack the
monarchy Aller and here's the difference
between what Diana used to do and what
these two are doing it's their
deliberate diminishing and Relentless
attacks on the family and the monarchy
that I really find offensive now and I
don't understand why if you're going to
attack the institution this much and you
hate the family this much why would you
want to a stay a member of that family
or be keep titles bestowed On You by the
monarchy and the family I I appreciate
that you find it personally offensive
peers but should I tell you what I find
concerning that in this discussion about
racism we know that the institution has
issues we know that in 2021 we were
supposed to see the appointment of a
diversity Zar and I'm still waiting for
that appointment what is a diversity Zar
we can disc we can discuss that another
day Lous Ty well P this is important
this is important the royal family
employ a lot more nonwhite people don't
want to hear it don't want it's a fact
that they employ a lot more non-white
people than they used to right it's also
a fact they remain exclusively white
other than the mega marle part of it
because they're were a white family here
don't shut me down on this point because
this is important for us you're
distracting away from the alleged racism
in this story Trevor Phillips Trevor
Phillips who ran the the big what's Happ
here no no I'm asking you a question
about this particular topic I haven't
finished answering your first question
talking about other things I'm not
talking about other things I'm talking
about exactly what you're referencing
the allegation of racism and why it's
important for the for society as a whole
for for us to see that the institution
is dealing with this and I'm saying to
you where is the diversity what racism
that we were what racism where is the
diversities are that we were told was
going to beo appointed in we were told
that this was such an important thing
and that it was going to happen where's
the racism of the
concerns RIS concerns that Megan had
that's what wased concerns secondly she
didn't even hear also we've also had
hear it and by the way she thought it
happened when she was pregnant Harry
said it happened before they got engaged
down is not going to change the fact I'm
concerned so we also have reports don't
we about issues in relation to how the
institution approaches the concerns
about about
racism we've had unfortunate stories RIS
where I accept there was an apology left
a concern didn't it when for example
princess Michael attended the dinner
wearing
herach do honestly believe Charles
racist about that baby know about the
issue in
relation lady hussy and and how that was
dealt with and what I'm saying to you is
is that there are concerns that have
been raised and it we know about the
concerns that were raised what I haven't
seen to deflect those concerns pouring
hatred on Harron and Megan that's what
this is about this is about hatred of
Harry and Megan pour more hatred over
people than these two who for four years
have poured hatred on their family and
the monarchy and who did it by sparking
a racism r on Oprah Winfrey in front of
50 million people where they made
allegation of racism and then try to
pretend they hadn't they've never
produced any evidence I mean Kevin this
is my my issue with this whole thing and
it does incense me that we are trying to
deal with a story which at the heart of
it I don't think there's even a story I
don't think this ever happened as Trevor
Phillips said at worst what we may be
dealing with is that someone in the
royal family Charles Kate whoever may
have said I wonder what what color the
baby might be that's not racism no you
have a mixed race relationship it's what
every mixed race relationship family
would ask themselves why do we keep
leaving out at the word concerns why do
we keep leaving that word out because
what are the concerns I I read Trevor
Phillips account because he's a black
Britain who's long campaign against
against Against Racism there L problems
with the institution but Megan markle's
evidence wouldn't stand up in court
because it was hearsay it's something
she said RIS allegations no no but it's
hearsay she hasn't heard it directly but
of course they should be stripped of
those titles and I think Harry's
grandmother the queen made a mistake not
taking them away I think his father
Charles now the King has made a mistake
not taking them away they said they
wanted to start a new life but that new
life actually requires them to have
those titles because their meal ticket
is trashing the royal family I'm
intrigued the the failure wasn't in in
about talking the failure wasn't in
about resolving the problem is you still
believe there was racism even Trevor pH
said he obvious very careful I have said
that I could believe it because I don't
know we need you don't think you should
be incumbent on those who made the
allegations to actually say what
happened um why are they silent in the
last week I I think what's intriguing is
is that you have asked them to be silent
for so long and now you are demanding
that they speak if they do speak
demanding they terfy think
you'll the boy they cooperated with on
the last book why he's able to let
Harry's father right and his sister-in
law as too racists and they say nothing
they say nothing do you think that if
you continue to shout me down I think
you got to answer some question at some
stage you allowed me literally are behav
like a politician if you allowed me to
if you can if you allowed me to the fact
is should they respond to this
absolutely they should respond to this
should King Charles and and Kate have an
opportunity to respond to it absolutely
do you know what I would like to see in
terms of a response i' would like to be
see a joint response I would like them
to come together out joint response
don't talk to each other well they need
to find call of they need to find
somebody who does because this isn't
unusual peers the fact that this is a
for out in a family is Not
Unusual Kevin wants them to be stripped
of their titles uh Bob cely wants them
to be stripped of their tit I want them
to be stri the fact remains that you
could strip them of the titled Duke and
duess of susic but you cannot remove the
fact that he is a prince of the blood
you stop call stop calling him the I
don't think you can I
think